okay then blended cozy hobby start
puddings - real statues near our table
yes I don't understand I mean like at
least get a statue that doesn't smell
bad again he's a hobo oh my god it is
it's right how about uh you know I I
always ask my parents for their hobo go
password no Logan it's a person without
a home
oh thank you my mom exactly okay first
of all we have to be nice to him because
remember in that movie The Lion King or
everybody is one no matter what type of
animal you are that's what we have to
follow yeah we're all one just like what
the hippie say
like if somebody came inside of me and
then I had to give birth to a baby like
he would be the type of smile that would
be inside that baby's diaper like oh my
god he smells like a little elephants
too sorry sir but we're not just gonna
give you money I don't want you to give
me money I'm not looking for a handout
you not entertainment am i right
I mean I went to Jonas Brothers last
night for free because that connection
but I don't feel like bragging about it
she liked entertainment do you like
entertainment well I feel like you leave
it up and I have a change of heart about
even money after you hear his guinea
noble training
Oh mom you want to map celebrate is here
buddy
and old lamp in it without goodbye
goodbye goodbye goodbye
okay first of all he does have some
potential like if he could take a shower
if he knew what a shara was he could
totally make it on a stage I could
totally see him as like being Marvin
Gaye's Little Nicky poo all right I did
maybe you don't like music as much as
you live me to me
so that's on you that's not me could I
put it on the line and it was very good
then damage it is relaxed animality I
mean I like to see when people fall on
America's Funniest Home Videos do you
think that's funny yeah sure why not
how hard he is to take a dump without a
pickle jar
no yes Logan don't bring that up you
were drunk that night you want to erase
those memories sorry sorry no right to
take it back in with the minister anyway
I'm sorry it didn't really impress me
much I have no regrets and I would do it
again in a heartbeat I mean a lot of
friends knock knock is that more your
speed
nah nah who's there
people who don't appreciate
sophisticated humor not now stare Oh No
okay Lee first of all like I understand
that probably he needs some help and
like I am NOT in the movie to help right
now I feel like Bill Cosby would have a
message opener complaint put in about
you two
you like acting like I took my Pinot
this morning no no no we swore off hobos
no no no no no no we're hope it's no
more skaters then we're scanners no row
hobos no more boat I can't like I need
it like I need it like okay you have a
cigarette